massacre 16 out of 25 from the stripe
they lead by 11 will under three minutes
left three sticks Jay rich with 21
points rich in straightaway three
Richardson's second tray of the game
Derek Jones jr. led Miami with 14
McGruder had 13 cigarettes able to break
down the defense off the trip draaga
strives on quarter sends it out to
Richardson for the quick three kaboom
and look out Whiteside and Markieff
Morris get tangled up and both men are
shaken up
- - e43 it's Richard in Kabul
Josh Richardson with 18 points now that
was his fourth triple of the game a
chance for the heat to reclaim the lead
Richardson's three does it Josh
Richardson a ten-point fourth quarter
and a 25 point game about how he's
asserting himself the confidence right
now rising king rich looking to take
over big shot here in the fourth playoff
rebound or Richard - well they heat play
the second night of a back-to-back in
Washington on Thursday the Hornets on
the second out of a packed attack
tonight Richardson from dent town
and the heat off to a seven nothing lead
two-point lead for the GEEP - bittitan
little food for Richard to the stream
coming second triple of the night
[Applause]
Richardson three in transition
[Applause]
Richardson's three Josh Richardson stem
points in the first 40 Center eight
minutes left down by 13 points screams
from Van Driessen Richard city trouble
keeps the defense off from there let the
defense fly by to make that mid-range
jump shot Richardson's long angle three
kaboom Richardson a pair of first
quarter threes he has nine points from
Miami two minutes into the second
quarter was one point lead for the heat
Richardson cut moon Josh Richardson is
26 triple the season this is a lemon he
is back to Dragon four and a half
minutes to go
Richardson big three from Richardson's
eat on the shot clock
trakax little stutter step bounces back
for a Richardson three Oh
watch Jay rich stepping up when it
matters is he with the big triple their
seven points in the overtime period to
leave the heat of a hand for members
number two of the league is Whiteside
and 15 and a half quarts again another
heat triple is young Whiteside gets his
first block of the game right side the
NBA shot locking leader at over three
rejection tonight Richardson kaboom
Jay rich barring his first two triples
tonight former shot clock Richardson
gets it off
knocks it in vodka pulled for Richardson
and here comes Miami last call
Richardson sets for the three kaboom
he's tied his career-high with seven
triples extra pass to the corner by
Tyler sets up Jay
he's Jedi from there lost nine of their
last 12 games a desperately are seeking
victory here tonight
Richardson straightaway three couple
Richardson has taken over the game will
clickers the heat and the Raptors coming
up Sunday night at six 534 heat line
six on the shot clock for Miami
Richardson's three yes for Toronto ties
the most that the Heat have given up
this year Miami gave up 125 in a road
loss at Charlotte also the worst team in
terms of managing the basketball the
average 18 turnovers the game they're
gonna turn it over and give you
opportunities Richardson drills a triple
and drew the foul on Henry we're talking
about they're gonna review this see if
he was beyond the art he will barely was
there with room to go there comes Miami
away dish to bayonetta Meyer switches on
a chair rich he'll fire a three
Richardson with
32 seconds left of the third quarter
Richardson catches fires
the 14 rebounds and Richardson 13 points
that's his only friend after Richardson
a long triple truck
Chuck strategy
to the game but he's triple twice in the
second half left block you can go to the
middle with the hook or shoot that
turnaround jumper to the baseline I'm
gonna push him off that blocks as much
as possible
Richardson there he's a long three
[Music]
Richardson left free from a triple
kaboom Davis was on him and backed off
at the last instant is a 29 footer out
by the half spark no hesitation when he
gets those feet set it pointing the
melenik mark is at seven
[Applause]
[Music]
and they rent looking a little like
James Harden unlimited range on that
contract because he does have that kind
of value on their roster his Richardson
Oliver house
it's the biggest lead for the Miami Heat
Richardson a deep three line drive home
run for Richardson the game see him
coming right at Olynyk Whiteside gets
his first block of the night fights had
number three in the league in blocks
this year Richardson's three coming over
and just pick it off without
over-committing and right down the floor
with numbers two Johnson with a rebound
right now the Heat are swarming two
seconds left third quarter Richardson
yes a triple for Josh Richardson the in
the third quarter orchid Phoenix the
Vixen sons are both nine and 29
there's a long one by Richardson Kapoor
Shaad for Richardson Richardson against
a very good defender in a reason he
reaches him not to free BAM right there
nears rich for three company he's done
it he's set a new record for the heat he
is sworn by poles so at it comes to
Johnson Richardson stepped into the
throne a couple really good kicked out
past there by Hasan hit six on the shot
clock
Richardson double
Josh Richardson on fire for dam on the
screen
topside Richichi come
[Applause]
to the rescue from the neither 7 424
nice steel pirate Future 3 obtuse breaks
of the heat
wait back to Jay rich wide open simply
[Applause]
Douglas Alexander played some point
guard last year at Kentucky but Doc
Rivers feels he has the necessary skills
to do that the NBA that's a three from
downtown it's good it's in the injured
goran dragic to Winslow five on the shot
clock
long three for Richardson here's Johnson
into the corner McGruder topside
Richardson come on the ball movement
almost led you to believe that
Richardson would finish with a splash
the ball movement has been very good in
this first quarter multiple passes
starting on the left side going all the
way to the right and reliable screen
centered remind every 10 minutes
Richardson chip each other through
kaboom
Josh Richardson is on fire the two-point
lead for the Warriors just over 5
minutes left in there's 13 Richard to
stern
bottoms up night for Josh Richardson he
is on fire he offensive Annan's j.r it's
beyond the arc
he's just so wishing on that release
Warriors with a four-point lead
still tied by Richardson three come on
Richardson he's done it with 13 points
and 22 well-played Dennis Richardson
good look at a three kaboom Josh
Richardson
backs up what about the three three of a
shot clock Richardson
back-to-back triples for Richardson
keeping hope alive
Allen ball movement on the perimeter
gifts Jay rich the open look
stepping in that's funny eat with a
12-point lean 6:35 left in the third
quarter Richardson three come on that's
got a help Tampa and 16 for Richardson
three of his four triples of count of
the second a thousand fourteen finals
against Miami Deon slipping to the
baseline setting up Richardson Jay rich
come on the two teams both playing zone
defense for much of this half Richardson
opened three yes but always pretty to
see the end of the rainbow
split becomes James Johnson good getaway
trip another son school dr. Richardson
for the three-ball
that's a couple of threes for Richardson
in the first quarter home crowd is
genuine shows the home team rate changes
direction after Richard sir fakes it now
fires
[Applause]
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content